PHIL: The prize for the biggest
crystal is a lunch
with John and the TAs at Legal
Seafood, which I'm personally
very excited about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Today the students are
going to learn a totally
different technique,
recrystallization.
PHIL: Pesticides,
pharmaceuticals, food
colorings, and products where
they have to produce tons per
year, recrystallization
is the key method.
Yesterday you were working
with about 100
megs of each compound.
Today, you're going to be
working with 2 grams.
NARRATOR: But there's more on
the line than just getting
those 2 grams back.
This is practice for next week's
crystal competition.
If the students do well, they'll
have a better shot at
winning a free lunch with
the teaching staff.
The first step in a
recrystallization is to choose
the right solvent.
The students need a liquid that
will not dissolve the
target molecule when it's cold,
but will dissolve it
when it's hot.
The students then dissolve the
sample in hot solvent and
filter out any solid
impurities.
Then they cool it down
in an ice bath.
The target molecule should
crystallized out of solution
forming a pure solid.
The impurities should
stay in the liquid.
ANTHONY: Fresh.
IKE: Yep.
That's how we want it.
Crystal clear.
NARRATOR: Ike, Ethan, and
Anthony are having
no problems at all.
ETHAN: Ain't nothing too hard
for an MIT chemist.
NARRATOR: Hansol, Jason, and
Fred on the other hand--
HANSOL: I made like two,
actually three mistakes today.
JASON: I've made so many
stupid mistakes today.
HANSOL: Yeah, I didn't realize
it would heat that fast.
FRED: Um, it exploded all over
the side of my flask.
HANSOL: And then it exploded,
so then I had to start over.
PAUL: It started sputtering
out and actually
it was kind of scary.
Some of it almost like
hit me in the face.
JASON: I've broken
a test tube.
HANSOL: And then I put it
through a small funnel which
was a total mistake.
JASON: I put too much solvent
losing some product.
HANSOL: The funnel,
I just dropped it.
So--
JASON: The yield on this
is almost nothing.
NARRATOR: After filtering,
washing and drying, everyone
eventually makes it to the
final step, weighing the
purified crystals.
Getting 90% yield is the goal.
That would be 1.8 grams of
the original crystal.
LEALIA: So far my yield
says 1.9 grams.
So I don't know if that's right
because there is only
supposed to be two grams.
JULIE: That's probably not going
to be that good because
that all I have.
There were some problems with
filtering and then also
noticed trying to put the stuff
in the beginning, I
spilled it everywhere.
YI-SHIUAN: Is it really pure?
JULIE: 7%.
LEALIA: 101% yield.
JULIE: Good job.
JASON: 3%.
So besides 3% yield, my melting
point's almost perfect.
NARRATOR: For some today,
a good start.
For others--
JASON: 3% yield.
You needed 90%.
I only got 3%.
NARRATOR: Not looking so
hot for next week.
Tune in, and see how
it all unfolds.
PHIL: Just make observations,
write down what could have
went wrong, what you could
do differently next time.
JASON: Not spill.
Sleep more beforehand so
I don't make mistakes.
Not spill.
PHIL: Take your vitamins.
JASON: Not be an idiot.
I don't know.
[MUSIC PLAYING]